I'm going to show you one reason why
using a OneNote 3D camera is oftentimes
better than using a two node 3D camera
when animating the 3D camera with a two
node setup you have to set double the
amount of keyframes that means one set
of keyframes for the camera's position
and another set for the camera's Target
this can be a tedious and time consuming
process especially if you're working
with a lot of keyframes and need to make
changes to the animation later on having
more keyframes also means an increased
chance of getting unwanted motion within
the camera path on the other hand with a
OneNote camera you only need to apply
one set of keyframes for the camera's
position this makes the animation
process much simpler and more efficient
so when it comes to working with 3D
layers in After Effects using a one node
camera is often the better option